how you feel about next weeka on dancing
you got your ready for a Monday night
yeah the team competition it should be
good I have two dances though so that's
like double the pressure double the
pressure and two dancers from here on
out I think I did
thanks looks so good Thanks bullying me
no I think so I'm least two sometimes
three I don't know hey I'm really know
more than I do
well you know you're welcome how do you
think he's doing I think he's doing
great he's practicing really hard he
does a great partner so I'm really proud
of him you know and it's it's a lot I
mean the schedule the rehearsal schedule
the pressure not I mean to how I did the
show back in season five I was on this
and it from in me and my marriage you
put a little but it was a little tricky
at the time I was traveling flatterer
how's it I mean is it affecting the the
couple ship at all yeah yeah like I'm
like I thought dancing hours were going
to be a lot longer so I finally more
like a nine-to-five job so he's out of
the house I'm working on my foundation
so we're both pretty busy but we make
time for each other again of the day so
that's what counts the new season
Bachelorette if you heard anything any
inside scoop now that's a locked vault
out over there
so we're just kind of doing our own
thing
[Music]
you
[Music]